yeah you did our you did our show i do a
weekly um
a sketch show that was like more called
a sketch show that was more craig what
you did those early stages now i do a
bunch of different like craig is my
favorite character really yeah talk to
me like craig for just a second what's
going on you guys you're just you know
check out the youtube channels
[Music]
the funniest videos i've ever seen it
was survivor yeah that's where
that's the video yeah that's the video i
saw and i went oh my god this is great
and then not knowing i was terrible at
um pranks
which i appreciate i was terrible
here's why i'm bad prankster because i
don't go for the jugular which you have
to do
and then i laugh
if something happens oh you were great
on this show you didn't
i
there was one with this it was full
release yoga remember this that's like
this these professional farters and this
poor girl put on put on how we do it
fully
no no
i was laughing then the poor girl
started crying
the girl cried
but i do feel bad for her i feel like
craig and miranda singh would have a
good youtube video too this is watch
this video so this is a video where this
woman and you don't have to watch if
you're watching on youtube but you can
listen to this so there's a woman in the
room who comes to
she believes
that she is um
making a video for this new kind of yoga
master
right who was originally me and i had to
be replaced i kept laughing wait it's
not you part of it's me but there it is
i got replaced like halfway through so
the girl you'll hear the only female
voice is the girl and then i hired the
farter from um
yeah full release yoga is different from
your normal yoga and that's why we
brought in these two guys with a very
special talent
so they can fart on command use your
imagination and watch what we did
craig is the younger students have a
seat
is that me yeah
i want you all to follow will to the
pose
i want you all to reach into your core
with your soul hand reach
down into your abdomen grab hold
of the trapped toxins
release it into the ether
keep in mind there are no sound effects
in this piece the farting is 100
real
[Music]
i did keep laughing but did it not stink
in the room it was awful and then i i
kept walking away and hear me get caught
back in the stage get caught back
because i kept laughing leave
but look at her face keep going keep
going watch her she's you you pulled it
you didn't maybe i should drink or
coffee
maybe i should drink more coffee
very good
are you hopeful shayna that you'll reach
this point
yes
did she do it i wait but definitely
hopeful definitely
shayna let's put you back in position
assume the cat position
[Music]
[Music]
these are dark
emotions
so you want to say welcome when they
come out welcome
oh my god
welcome
what is an animal that frightens you
shayna a jaguar a jaguar very good
you are a jaguar can you do the growl of
the jaguar and release
what's the next pose
peel if i may sorry it's all right it's
a very important release is that why you
came out but it was silent
i let one out but it was silent
he's not even dressed like get him out
there
because why you were laughing i kept
having to walk out and i was laughing
yeah i was not a good uh i wasn't good
at holding and laughing but it was funny
[ __ ] it was kind of hilarious especially
when you're right there it's so hard not
to laugh she was a good sport there was
another girl that cried how'd you find
her cried
how'd you find the guys that could fart
on command like that amazon
[Music]